allez les enfants on va se coucher
les garçons je vous ai dit pas regarder
ce genre de trucs avant de dormir ça
existe pas maman on risque rien oui mais
vous allez faire des cauchemars on
trouve des allusions à ce pas cool dans
toutes les cultures
certains pensent qu'il vit dans un autre
monde
d'autres racontent qu'il se nourrit de
la corruption de l'innocence elle et
qu'on communique avec lui par le biais
d'un rituel ou d'un sacrifice
il y a toujours trois éléments une
famille assassinée une maison
et une offrande des images de la
littérature de la musique il ya un
problème
j'ai trouvé une autre maison alors brûlé
là c'est pas aussi simple une famille
s'y installer tu comprends pas tu sais
pas ce qui va se passer et farias
si tu en parles vous tu toi et ta
famille et on regardera le film encore
et encore
pagny ans parce que le spectacle
commence